how's it going bros my name is beer
welcome to the Machine apparently this
is recently a release cousin story it
got great reviews for story I think I
never finish oh it's a pretty cool I
wanna try it sit here 1887 you and your
wife Nina have been invited to Lord
Henry's haha I wanna go to that feast
which is going to happen inside an own
man his on whatever at the countryside
of North fault I've been in Norfolk
pretty sweet actually have it the main
person of the event Lord Haris of
Norfolk was nicely regarded as an
eccentric and odd engineer due to his
researches on steam engines and engines
steam machine ready alright and that
night 8 19th of October 1887 after
several hours feasting you felt drunk
and I gotta go to the machine and you
made your way to a guest room you laid
on the floor and passed out pretty much
yeah alright that's probably pretty cool
cerebra sounds like a regular Friday
night uh-huh uh-huh
so bad shops are gonna happen what about
my wife we got there with our wife why
should i why I am disappointed why else
would you go with your wife I it's too
much for me I have a fun load
super-sick loading you guys don't you
bros don't see the loading screen but
I'm looking at it right now and it's
like herp a derp and I like come punched
let me play I'm ready there we go that's
a long load my son is it already that's
not good for anyone
oh okay that's a fireplace uh-huh
I passed out Jesus guys how much did I
drink last night
oh yeah yeah it looks like the party's
over but there's a whole little fire is
there someone there
Allah where's my I had a drink right
there I put an X ma soeur when I woke up
I would have it Jesus Christ what time I
think you can [ __ ] with my books you can
pay in my mouth but you don't take my
drink ah bucket there you are I looked
everywhere for you
okay I got Amba oh yeah
all right knock it thro hey when did my
bucket go oh wait I just feel better
that's it took the bucket you feel bad I
see I looked in the Box I looked
everywhere for you two and let's waste
it here alright so close now take one of
these before
the books are glued oh no this is not
good for anyone
so it closed it on the other side Anaya
Caramba
oh yeah yeah no no it's good Oh what the
[ __ ] did I miss a scare or something
what the [ __ ] happened
Jesus guys what was that psycho [ __ ]
don't tell me it wasn't my life I was
like all right this looks pretty oh no
my beloved Nina is gone haha pity I know
where she went
but I'm not gonna tell you first you how
much ash from s3 to write off hey I'm
sorry
absolutely I'm sorry pity I'm Sharpie
I'm just kidding let's go this way I
just knocked oh holy [ __ ] you just see
that balance how the [ __ ] do that how
did you do that mr. Shay I don't know Oh
mr. Sherr you're always so oblivious
okay what is - what is yes are you my
last inventions as for now I'm working
on something completely different the
machine I have I gotta say that dramatic
I have create no way I created some
space underneath my mansion to provide a
good life for my experimentation I'm
trying to use the steam and power source
my trust adviser based upon beside mr.
pawl tire group of specialists working
for me and a heart races well now
they're profiling well tomorrow we'll be
assessing its new same power dogs if I
think final mass production also I got
some new ideas for human my penis maybe
in closed future it will be able to make
mechanical human being this idea doesn't
let me sleep at night nah happening
and I'm a hater can we do anything about
these can we find anything in here oh
look at this I'm so happy now I'm so
happy now I have my lantern ye ye ye oh
oh no oh [ __ ] sniffing it my god is Lord
jeomsun love James and what time they
done to your delay they cut off your
penis
Oh Jameson anything but their penis oh
who are you
Wow something seriously weird I'm just
gonna take the 10 in box and you guys
can just keep on rolling all right
large James pour large Jameson and I
walk right on it all right I think it's
time to go here actually yep yep it's
time to go buddy it's time to use my
super strength
come on yes
wait ah now it broke can I keep it with
me as protection
what is everybody what is the potted ego
happening haha pity hell up an out Jesus
Christ is only mr. Sharon Oh what is the
outs okay and we got a nananananana
nananananana will get light Nana Nana
Nana Nana Nana
oh hello that son ran ran out of mana an
hour now now now Aladdin had a plan how
do you say to be careful alright I'm a
chef let's party
he's oh man don't you remember last
night you were so drunk you showed up
with it you were dancing there I was
like ah Jesus guys when he wakes up he's
gonna be so embarrassed ah that was good
times
oh man alright wait that's just I don't
trust you and your penis hey my ancestry
I think iding here
tell me all your secrets okay hello
Perry how God you can't go there
can't go that high pity how are you dad
hey that's a bit bouncy table everyone
else is how you walk normally like if
you've got to get somewhere a table is
always the fastest way to walk alright
Wapiti a lot of missus shares in this
mod anything suspicious huh
private in the box everyone period that
means me nice clothes let's try this
story
oh god this is creepy ah hey yeah I'm
pumped
no they don't move that way then we do
move hey don't be so friggin pump I'm
Tom I'm pump even it on dead yeah you're
that guy you like that I smack my dead
but I'm doing wah you like that you like
when I cry all right all right
oh you can seriously [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
here what did nothing alright potatoes
barrels are you hiding something from me
I know you are hiding now just bounce up
Wow
right yeah hate you so much okay what'd
I do huh well you try to hide from me
Bella we don't need no water let that
barrels per burn barrels
[Music]
this is a lot of hair talk alright see
what that son of a [ __ ] hid from me Oh
happening
I heard you look for a lot of hair right
here wait like stone-cutting see ya
alright it's like a list of stuff
alright dip ha please well these cup
down the cuts tell the way I stopped
working outside ice way don't leave them
now also I'd like to see your weekly
part why big night Jase gotta piss off
Englishman can't be pissed off this
sounds weird
Jay I'm so pissed off right now there is
something in sign call sir bruh come on
come on brah crap what am i doing I
don't I don't get it
where's the father soon as that voice
the funnel gonna go here please oh [ __ ]
what do you want from me sofa huh
what do you want from me mister sofa so
we pull a lever I'm not sure what the
[ __ ] we did went in to do it now but
let's try that try and go maybe maybe
tables I love tables table I like trees
dixit click no wait
that's it can go there maybe here come
on what do you want from me oh I think
you're supposed to pull I think I read a
lot of people who are stuck at this part
and you're supposed to pull the lever
more than once or something like that
wow it was yeah you tried you thought I
was done one yeah ha stupid barrels hey
hey ha I'm stuck back back
Vale's what ok let's do it a couple more
times
miss jerk the lever a couple more times
I like that you like that you like that
alright
I'm not wasting my Ola hey I heard
something I heard something Mitch niffle
for shizzle that rhyme actually that was
point all right let's try why why why
dad me tell me why I am movie oh I am
that's a foul no but I know I am from
long long time ago
I will tell you four times all right
let's you have to do it one more time
yeah I just said for Turkey you have to
do it one my god damn in your prison now
then we go back here and then we go and
click the other doors and then the far
time it should break hey wait
yep yep first times charm no wait three
times Shawn yeah yeah come on oh I knew
that Scarlett what are you doing I was
just experimenting I'm sorry if I scared
ya it was not my intention I am a
scientist and sometimes things doesn't
work out okay but if you want to escape
from this place because that hell on you
I already took it up well
okay but I promise next time that'll be
my calf oh okay good
Jesus Christ she's kidding living crap
out of me Scully so we used to hollow
kneel to lockpick the door I would
assume maybe bump bump bump here maybe
or the other door I don't even know
nope I need to keep it that long you
should have said that before man
okay now can you do that way either
I'm did you play I'm just pawning idea
hey then you need to use it for it are
you liar you need to use it for that so
it's either it has to be this store are
you kidding me what do you want from me
have hiccups now are you happy
all right happening hi buddy already huh
where's the door is there you have to
pull the lever fart oh Jesus
no but why instead of chefs or something
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah there we go hello
how girl not by much double kill they'd
never expected anything they're like hey
we're just that's it oh you got the key
to cool metal key
but father that okay just here's come
fitting just be quiet
don't make noise you see and maybe does
break us double kill
it lacks oh god this is creepy there's
just creepy creepy alright
sorry bros but I'm actually gonna end in
here and like a favorite doll I kind of
stuff and I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
my babies I don't gap Damon